au boeuf ou au poulet la brochette et
l'incontournable des barbecues de l'été
steve elle a 19 ans et depuis début mai
il en prépare plusieurs centaines par
jour
un emploi estival qui lui permet de
financer ses études de kinésithérapie le
matin je commence à 6 heures dans les
bassins coeur je viens ici
coupe des poivrons la viande déjà prête
par les bouchers et après j'ai que a
enfilé toute la journée les brochettes
ça me plaît enfin je suis très content
au début au début ça me paraissait un
petit peu dur et au final on s'habitue
vite et le rythme et il se prend il se
prend facilement six morceaux de légumes
pour cinq morceaux de viande un poids
compris entre 180 et 220 g la brochette
est parfaitement calibré plus d'un
million sont réalisés par l'enseigne
d'avril à septembre
en ile-de-france nouveau vient de
recherche une centaine de collaborateurs
comme stivell un contrat à temps partiel
pouvant devenir à temps plein en
fonction de la météo
on travaille en partenariat avec météo
france on la reçoit la météo tous les
jours tous les matins et donc en
fonction de la météo on appelle nos gros
shooteur actuellement dans le secteur
des yvelines nous recherchons une
vingtaine de brewster
donc si vous êtes motivés vous êtes
jeanne disponibles vous pouvez postuler
la vente de brochettes représentent 20%
du chiffre d'affaires de nouveaux viande
rémunérés au smic le métier de brewster
a été breveté par l'enseigne selon un
sondage réalisé par opinionway en 2014
75 % des français déclarent pratiquer le
barbecue les brochettes sont prêtes
il ne reste plus qu'à les déguster et
attendre le retour du sonnet